foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right hello everybody and welcome to
daily with Doc let's go ahead and open
up the doors here in the live Zoom room
and if you are catching us out as a live
stream on any of the platforms that we
are watching or even on the radio you
are more than welcome to join us here in
our Zoom room by simply going to daily
with Doc zoom.com so put that in the URL
not necessarily in the search bar but in
the URL daily with Doc zoom.com and
you'll be able to access our live
meeting Monday through Friday from 12 to
12 50 p.m Pacific time the nice thing
about it is you calculate whatever time
that is in your time zone you can access
us and if you can't access this during
that time we do have all of our replays
on our YouTube channel make sure that
you're following critical Health news
out on YouTube Facebook critical health
and on Rumble look for critical health
or daily with Doc and hey better yet
just do a search of daily with Doc
and you'll find us on your favorite
platforms and once you find us go ahead
and give us a little thumbs up subscribe
put in a comment let us know where you
are tuning in from so that we know that
we are out reaching people where they're
at because folks we are a group of
individuals who have a heart for people
so we bring our skills together so that
we can reach people in our own
communities and together we can reach
around the world in sharing the message
of hope that hope being that you do not
have to be stuck in dis-ease you do not
have to be stuck with what the that
label of having something that's quote
unquote genetic
and holding you back from being able to
enjoy life because folks I've been there
I know what it's like to think well I'm
just gonna have to deal with this the
rest of my life well
I am honored to be able to bring this
program to you because I don't have to
deal with those quote unquote genetic
things the rest of my life because of
the doctor that we share here on this
program
I have been able to overcome so many
different things in my own health that
now allows me to thrive and not just
barely survive hoping to make it through
tomorrow so folks without further Ado I
just want to
congratulate you on finding this program
if somebody shared this program with you
make sure that you get back with them
and tell them thank you thank you for
taking the time thank you for thinking
of me enough and caring about me enough
to share this information with me so get
back with that person
if you have found this program all on
your own and there is nobody to think
and you would like to get in contact
with a coach to help guide you on this
journey because it is a journey folks
you can go to
855-949-3377 again that's
855-949-3377 and you can get in contact
with one of our coaches to help guide
you on this program
now we also have a website on this
website make sure that you go there make
sure that you subscribe to our
newsletter because we send out the
replays once a week from the previous
week giving descriptions of the programs
so that you can easily find them do a
search for them and then share them with
somebody that you know that can relate
to something that is talked about on
that show
that's how we are going to help make a
stronger healthier World Folks by you
jumping in and sharing the information
that you hear with somebody else you're
not hearing it just to hear it you're
hearing it because it has
a purpose you have a purpose and if you
would like to use your purpose in
helping more and more people
we have a spot for you on our team
person to share this program with you
probably has a spot for you on their
team and as teams we work together to
help the communities so
that's
the program the content of this program
is to provide educational purposes only
it is not meant to take the place of
your primary care physician nor are the
products
to diagnose treat prevent or cure any
disease the FDA does require us to tell
you this but folks whenever you give the
body what it absolutely needs not just
to survive but actually Thrive the body
can do some amazing things and the only
reason why we know what the body needs
to thrive is because the doctor that we
have with us
has over 30
000 autopsies under his belt
okay
he has done the research he has figured
out when something was missing hey
it's not by chance that some disease
disease was occurring
so he took all of this information
connected the dots put together a
program that actually supplies the body
with the nutrients that the body needs
and those secret sauces to help fill
those gaps where decline has already
started
so I am honored and privileged to share
with you the doctor that helped give me
my life back Dr Joel Wallach he has a
Bachelor of Science in agriculture he
has a doctor of veterinary medicine
which folks when you lose hope in the
medical system
the veterinarian is the best place to go
so we have the veterinarian in the house
with Decades of research around the
world not just research but actually
implementation
who has three post doctorates in
pathology and if that wasn't enough
after teaching nutrition at the college
level he became a naturopathic physician
so that he could legally give
recommendations to us human folks so Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
so happy to have you here with us today
and you know I've had a lot of emails
and questions come in that are related
to the nervous system
so can you tell us a little bit about
the nervous system what is its purpose
and then I would like to go into
because I have too many folks that are
asked that are saying that they're
considering having the nerves burned
because of pain
tell us what that does how it benefits
how it harms just lay it out doc
okay well thank you Becca for the kind
introduction and thank you for the team
uh welcome everybody
well the nerves are very special there's
a communication system in your body from
your body to the brain from the brain to
the body
and of course when you look at the com
it's actually quite complicated on one
hand but on the other hand it's not
complicated I just think about it the
brain the spinal cord goes out of the
back of the skull
and I haven't even talked about the 12
pairs of cranial nerves yet okay but
just the spinal cord comes out of the
back of the brain okay there's a 12
cranial nerves gotta go farther in the
book to see the spinal cord
here's the one now you notice there's a
brain the spinal cord comes down it
splits at the shoulder level so it has a
big nerve going down to each arm down to
the fingers okay then and the nerve goes
down through the chest and IT Supplies
information to the lungs the lung Supply
information to the spinal cord the
spinal cord supplies information to the
heart and and so forth and then it goes
down into the belly okay abdominal
um version of the spinal cord it tells
the stomach and intestines what to do
the kidneys what to do in the liver what
to do and it goes on down into the
pelvis and splits at the sacral level
and for sciatic nerves so if that nerve
gets squeezed you it's called sciatica
pain dysfunction all kinds of stuff
maybe one layer both legs depending on
if how high up that injury and the
spinal cord is now you look at that
spinal cord you look at all the major
nerves coming out of there they take
messages out to every cell in the body
and then every cell in the body puts
information back into the nerves going
back up into the brain I mean you can
tell your brain without even verbalizing
you just think it blink your eyes you
blink your eyes you can say Okay I want
to swallow you swallow you don't even
have to verbalize it you just think it
um you can fan yourself because it's
kind of hot outside and humid and you
don't even have to say anything you just
say to yourself oh I need to fan myself
so you just reach up take your hand or
just your hand and fan yourself a little
bit that's major Communications but also
we're talking about blood sugar levels
we're talking about blood oxygen levels
we're talking about anemia we're talking
about fever and of course Rebecca talked
about the hot stuff you put your hand on
the hot oven your your if you do it
slowly enough
your nerves will tell you it's hot
before you actually touch it because
you'll feel the heat a couple inches
above the hot
um griller oven okay
and it was probably one of the most
clever things that God did when he made
um vertebrates because all vertebrates
have brains and spinal cords and that
kind of stuff and this is what allows us
to survive in all the different
environments because we have to have a
micro environment that we all optimize
okay proper temperature proper
um
Breeze and proper everything humidity
and so on
and
if if one's a little one degree off
your nerves tell your brain okay and
your brain says okay we'll only do
something here okay and so
um this is something what a miraculous
part of the body most people never see
the nerves okay you know about them you
feel them you know what they're doing
for you okay but you rarely see them
this is something you see at anatomy
class is an autopsy and that kind of
stuff now you can actually see it now
MRIs okay
magnetic resonance
imaging you can actually see the the big
nerves okay with that
and they require an enormous amount of
nutrition not just sugar okay they
require
the same thing your brain spinal cord
requires all the all the nerves your
body require okay this is the
um the white matter of the nervous
system myelin okay and guess guess what
myelin is made out of uh cholesterol
cholesterol
yeah cholesterol and doctors say
cholesterol is bad because the clouds
your arteries that's not true okay that
was that was a mistake big mistake that
made over a hundred years ago
okay but your nerves the coating okay
the nerve coating it has a high
significant portion of cholesterol could
be 25 50 75 depending on what part of
the body you're talking about the closer
you get to the brain the bigger
percentage of cholesterol is involved
okay
and
um this goes back to the beginning of
time we see the same thing in mummies uh
you know and of course we actually see
those sort of things when we used to
make drawings of bodies and corpses
thousands of years ago okay they knew
about nerves they didn't know everything
that nerves did but they knew if you
um chopped your hand okay was just the
other hand you can feel that and that
goes up your arm okay up your neck into
your brain your brain saying hey stupid
what are you doing stop chopping your
hand here
okay and so this is something we have to
give
the the central nervous system the brain
and the spinal cord and all the major
nerves and mind